it looks like you're in a timeout you
have to sit in the corner right you want
to send it no I don't want to sit in
I'm anxious to kind of see what she goes
through in the course of a day and she
works with the directors and I'm not
sure exactly although I think when Alex
realizes that I'm staying for the day
she's gonna be thrilled I want coffee
anyway so I'll drink some coffee
it's Brooke like what
why Oh make sure you save some for me
what what are you doing here
hi I get to spend the day with you oh
the whole day what is happening why is
my mom here shouldn't you be at school
all nervous the whole time cuz she likes
to doing well it's just a little bit
there it was like a like a horse being
kept behind a gate before race you're
like like just waiting to jump in some
story there
yeah like the pepper Cheney roast yeah
like you're better to go you could taste
test whiskey and stuff like that yeah
just as someone my age watching I like
stories I like to know the connection
with people mom still dirty jokes oh my
god that would be so good
I feel like this meeting was productive
sorry yeah for me to explain anything
about technology to her I'm just like
it's not even worth it should I know
that one no you don't need to know that
way all right where is that Oh or dare
mom this where it says description what
I don't know you're looking stop using
all this vocabulary that I do it's just
like a funny moving picture no I'm old
old people don't listen this is fun
would I do that and you get bored and
you want some other pay attention to you
across the way I go wait Oh seriously
you don't do that watching Alex as a
mother I look at her and I'm like oh my
god she's really grown up and you
actually did pretty good job with not
like trying to adjust me every presence
hey try a nut he was a little bit when
we talked on the phone like every day
but to have her here like sharing
this part of my life with her is pretty
cool now I'm gonna cry maybe this was a
lot of fun Dingle is from the team we go
to back so like every once in awhile if
you with you
I was kidding earlier I told her that
you said I could come once a month now
[Music]